Points and vectors don't require any numbers to be associated with them. For
example, I can say, define a vector from the Andromeda galaxy to Chicago. That
vector now exists, but doesn't have any coordinates until I define a frame of
reference of some sort. I could ask, what are the vectors coordinates in terms
of the Earth's latitude, longitude, and altitude? That gives one set of
coordinates, the one that changes every second as the Earth rotates. Or I could
ask, what are the coordinates in terms of the Sun's location and the Earth's
path, and get coordinates that change more slowly. Whenever we assign a point or
a vector a coordinate value, it's always with respect to some frame of reference
we've defined. In 3D computer graphics, we usually talk about the location and
movement of objects, lights and cameras, in terms of world space. This frame of
reference is usually right handed. You can define units for it if you like, such
as 1 unit equals 1 meter. Or it can be unitless, if there's no need for them.